the public just found out a few years
ago about Caitlyn when she made her
transition but my mom has known for
decades she's off living her life so
what I've learned is just to not expect
too much from her Brody Jenner has been
filling all sorts of stuff about Caitlyn
Jenner on the hills reboots my dad and I
have never really had a great
relationship and now we finally know why
a source tells Edie it's because quote
for years Caitlyn and the Kardashians
have been able to have their narrative
on everything now Brody has not let to
do it I didn't really grow up with my
dad I didn't really you know when I was
really little we got to spend a little
bit of time when he started you know
obviously the family with the Kardashian
family and all that I didn't really see
much of him our source says Brody and
Kaitlynn haven't had much of a
relationship for a really long time
adding they go through ups and downs of
time spent together or talking and then
no contact
Bruce was just never really around every
so often maybe once every couple years
wasn't around for my graduation wasn't
around for most of my birthday's so yeah
well it really wasn't any relationship
it was very surface eventually we
started to become the closer but then
all of a sudden it's like I was just
getting a note Bruce and then Bruce
became Caitlyn recently Brody and his
wife who was also named Caitlyn opened
up about how Brody's dad canceled on
their wedding a week before the ceremony
Brody really just kind of brushed it off
but he has to have felt something but he
doesn't express it it was it was
honestly it really did hurt but good
Caitlyn appear on the hills to address
her relationship with her son are we
gonna see any Kardashians any Jenner's
pop-up this season I don't know you're
gonna have to watch you find out I don't
know yeah I'm not really allowed to give
away any other stuff that's on the show
but maybe Caitlyn could appear it's yeah
there's always a possibility
[Music]